I am your host for today's webinar I'm
joining from all the way from Bangalore
India and simply learn to get ahead jish
a civil engineer turned data scientist
who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
University true champion who upskilled
to win big you on board and
a massive hike that transformed my life
Chang gears pretty early in the
race Russ wanted to explore more to get
ahead isar simply learned from
mechanical engineering to a data analyst
and a podcaster in his free time
transformation simply learn industry
expert dat
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that
longer didn't choose a quick fix he just
added data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a join family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nth from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passion
situation you too will find your way to
get ahead when you simply learn short
simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
hello everyone uh Russia Russia here all
the way from Bangalore India uh I'm
thrilled to be your host today uh I can
see a lot of introductions coming in on
chat here I can see Punam has joined
from kpur am has joined from Mumbai
Sandi from Kolkata I can see manut
manjun has joined from Bangalore I can
see Pauline has joined from Uganda I can
see tan has joined from
lakau uh Tino jini has joined from Sri
Lanka na has joined from Pakistan so
welcome everyone uh we'll be starting
the session before we start let's go
through the ground rules quickly so uh
if you have a question for our speaker
today h sham who's joined us already for
the session you can put down your
questions in the Q&A box also the
session is being recorded so in case you
want to go through the recording of the
session again you can expect a followup
email uh with record recording link
webinar certificate and also the bonus
offer for the program for attending this
webinar which will be revealing towards
the end and also to request appr proof
of attendance for this webinar you can
provide your name a full name uh in the
post webinar survey which you'll be
getting once the webinar ends uh I can
answer questions about the proof of
attendance towards the end of the
session so in case you have any
questions about that we'll have time for
that so once again welcome everyone uh
this this webinar is powered by simply
world's number one online boot camp uh
we are very proud that we have been in
the digital skills space for almost 13
years and we have advanced over 5 lakh
plus careers in over 150 plus countries
and we have 800 plus qualified trainers
in uh categories like AI machine
learning which will be covering today
data science business analytics cyber
security project management digital
marketing and many more like that so
once again welcome everyone for joining
the session and uh we'll be talking
about you let's go through the agenda
here getting to know more about about
you how we can help you out exactly when
it comes to career inim and we'll be
covering popular AI tools and Frameworks
in 2024 uh we'll be talking about
careers in a Ai and machine learning in
2094 and we'll talking about what the
program offers by I kpur and also how
this program gets you job ready taking
you through the enrollment steps of the
program and also there will be special
duration for the Q&A part so we'll try
to take as many questions as possible
throughout the session in case we are
not able to answer your question
throughout the session we answering
those towards the end so please don't
worry we'll address all of your queries
uh just make sure that it's related to
aim that's
all so before we start uh I just have a
quick Poll for you here as I said that
we will be basically getting to know you
a little better so uh I have just
launched this quick poll here where we
uh basically you need to answer
basically how many years of experience
do you currently have so there are four
quick options here you can choose the
one which is the most relevant for you
and uh I'll just just read out those
options here so how many years of
experience do you currently have just to
understand you know uh folks who have
joined uh come from different different
experien as usually so uh just to
understand that so currently studying is
the first option second option is zero
to three years third option is 3 to 5
years and the last one is more than five
years so as I was speaking I can see
folks have already started sharing the
responses on the poll so I think we have
gotten a really active audience here
active set of aspiring Learners here for
the AML uh TRS master class today so
I'll just give 10 seconds for the poll
here because I can see most of the folks
have already shared the responses uh for
a few of the folks who are still sharing
the responses in the pool please take
take 10 more seconds and I can see more
introductions coming on the chat here so
that's great I can see Aisha has joined
from Ethiopia Kelvin has joined from
Ghana and data data Tre has joined from
musk Oman please correct me if I
pronounced your name wrong uh so keep
the introduction actions coming in it's
always good to network right in these
events before we start we would love to
know you where are you joining us from
your name because sometimes we are not
able to make it out from your email ID
if you understand and I think most of
the folks have already shared the
responses for the poll here so I'll just
end this poll in 5 seconds
more so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end the
poll and also share the results with you
folks so as we can see uh I have shared
the results of the poll here so we had
asked the audience that how many years
of experience do you currently have and
we can see 42% of the folks who have
joined us have more than five years of
experience and completely opposite to
that 40% of the folks are currently
studying and so that's that's great that
we have gotten folks from almost every
experience here from uh you know no
experience to basically more than five
years of experience and few of the folks
have already shared responses for 0 to
three years of experience and 3 to 5
years of experience so thank you so much
for sharing that with us uh moving on uh
we already have a speaker here with us
sham Pand uh sham uh first of all would
like to welcome you to the
session and uh basically would like to
thank you for taking the time out and
you know taking us through this
interesting industry master class which
will be covering uh in the next upcoming
slides so uh would love to know your
introduction for the crowd here uh thank
you so much Rasha for setting up the
context and it's always my pleasure uh
to interact with the AI
enthusiasts those who want to learn Ai
and want to make their career in AI so I
carry close to uh 15 years of experience
in AI in data science my role in the
corporate has been into strategy
Consulting but apart from my work I have
always been in touch with academics I've
been training
corporates I've been training
individuals because teaching is my
passion so I have trained many Fortune
companies and lately we got associated
with BCG Singapore as well so it has
been a great association with simply
learn it has been more than eight years
with simply
learn thank you so much for introduction
and uh we are very glad to have you here
sham once again uh so I think uh let's
start with the session as we can see
there is a lot of folks who basically
are excited about the session so let's
talk about the popular AI tools and
Frameworks you know in 2024 exploring
The Cutting Edge technology shaping a
IML in the coming year so uh let's start
with the first slide here tensor flow
and P Dodge sure uh
so for deep learning uh these two
Frameworks are
used and it's not about 2024
they are uh in the market and people
have been using it since long but they
are evolving big time uh they are
keeping their Pace up to the requirement
of the
industry uh let me talk about tensor
flow I'll also talk about kasas which is
built on top of tensor flow and P
Tor so tensor flow I Believe is the most
popular and most robust deep learning
framework and these two tensor fluent
caras are pivotal tools in the realm of
AI and deep
learning tensor flow is developed by
Google it is also an open source
framework it is highly flexible
scalable it allows developers to
construct intricate machine machine
learning models offering extensive
support for both research and
production Keras uh is high level high
level when I say I mean it is built on
top of tensor flow so it's a high level
lural Network API that runs seamlessly
on top of tensor flow making it more
user friendly so you don't you you have
to write lesser number of quotes you
have to write little program and it
works amazingly
well kasas simplifies the process of
building neural networks enabling rapid
prototyping and
experimentation together these two
tensor fluent caras provide a very
potent ecosystem for developing and
deploying a wide range of AI
applications from
image and speech recognition to natural
language processing and a lot more than
that P Tor at the same time has picked
up very well recently otherwise it was
tensor flow all the
way it is widely used opsource deep
learning
framework and uh it is developed by
Facebook's AI research lab Fair
basically py to has gained popularity
among researchers and Developers for its
user
friendliness its pythonic ways of
walking it also has extensive Community
Support it it empowers users to build
and train complex neural networks with
utmost
ease it offers an intuitive way to
express
models uh and you know what I really
like its Dynamic graph features which
allows for dynamic computation
making it very suitable for tasks that
involve varying input
sizes or having very Dynamic nature
Dynamic
structures apart from that pyge offers
excellent support for GPU acceleration
as well enhancing the efficiency of deep
learning model training because
efficiency is a very important
aspect we always have tradeoff between
efficiency and
accuracy uh so
pyos has the
capabilities which make it a Top Choice
for various AI applications including
computer vision NLP reinforcement
learning and so on and so
forth can we move to the
next
please yeah now uh
you have built your model on
pyour and there are few things better in
tensor flow maybe you also have Keras
and some part of it is on Keras so how
you can change from one to
another okay so interoperability is very
important aspect and here comes this
Onyx open neural network exchange it's a
kind of game changer for AI model
portability it Fosters interoperability
between diverse deep learning Frameworks
I talked about that so that way it gives
you big flexibility so your friend has
built some model in pytorch and you have
done that in tensor flow and kasas and
you want to connect everything
seamlessly it is no more a challenge
that is very easy
now please next
slide yeah Transformers and uh they're
also evolving uh big
way keeping up to the pace of the
challenges coming up in
NP in fact uh everybody is moving
towards Transformer models so hugging
faces Transformers library is a kind of
goto choice for NLP tasks instead of
going for traditional
modeling instead of going for
traditional models like logistic
regression or support Vector machine or
for that matter naive
base uh people prefer always uh
Transformer models for
NLP okay so it provides a wide range of
pre-trained model for tasks such as text
classification in text Data sentiment
analysis is very critical that we can do
very easily with the help of
Transformers
translation all these things are very
easy to work with when we have
Transformer
models so yeah I agree that Transformers
have actually re re nationalized
NLP
absolutely uh next slide
please now
uh going forward uh you all are aware
how generative AI is
impacting how uh people who don't have
programming background people who don't
have a statistical background they also
want to try their hands on modeling they
also want to build their
models model building uh is a very
complex exercise where you go collect
the data then you uh perform data
manipulation transform the data
basically data pre-processing steps then
you build the model then after building
the model you have a lot of other
analysis then deployment a lot many
steps you
have automl has transformed that big
time so even for those people who are
not technically very well vered automl
has given way to build
[Music]
model okay so they are able to build
model with the help of automl tools like
Google automl Microsoft Azure automl so
it has actually in real sense
democratized the machine
learning machine learning for
all I'm sure you all must have been
using chat GPT so GPT models like
gpt3 are leading the way in enhancing
language experiences
gp4 on the
horizon ethics and fairness in a are
Paramount for sure and as AI
is moving into all the foras you can
think
about uh ethics AI ethics becomes even
more important to take care of so we
have tools which take care of this
aspect as
well now Quantum Computing along with
machine
learning that makes it even more
interesting so we have Frameworks like
quis kit
Sak they are actually very promising
where these two Fields come together to
solve real complex
[Music]
problems uh next slide
please so yeah thank you so much sham
for taking us through the tools and
Frameworks here uh now we'll be talking
about
in AIML uh in 2024 also just to let you
know that we have already started
getting you know some interesting
questions in the Q&A box here folks uh
so please do put down your questions in
the Q&A box I think rupes has also asked
for interesting question so please uh go
and put down in the Q&A box you can just
find it just beside the chat box it's
very easy to navigate and we'll be
addressing them pretty uh soon so let's
talk about uh EML careers uh in 2024
here so sure uh sure
so in 2024 and Beyond since the
requirements are changing because of
emergence of generative AI uh because of
evolution uh of AI as a whole the jobs
are also
changing
uh if you look at data science and data
engineers five years back there was big
difference between the roles now that
role is I mean both the roles are
changing and it is very difficult to
find out a demarcation line between the
two so you are required to understand
the database part as well as a data
scientist and for a data engineer it is
important to know the modeling part as
well very well so so uh so there's a
change and the focus is more towards the
logical aspect because we are moving
towards an era where we may not have to
write programs where the
syntax will be written by the tools only
we only will be focusing on the logical
part so it is important now that our
foundation is a strong it should not
only be about uh knowing the right
libraries and functions and somehow run
the code it is more about knowing the
fundamentals so that will be very
important here so in machine learning we
have
jobs we have roles into machine learning
engineer data engineer in AI we have ai
architect AI developer in data science
we have senior data scientist data
scientist roles so I think this
discussion should have given you an idea
about the new roles and what you should
expect and
what uh your recruiters the employers
are expecting out of
you uh thank you so much sham for for
taking us to the hotest tml jobs in 24
we are getting few questions you know
about the career paths here we'll be
taking those in some time uh let's talk
about the hottest skills in the aim
space which will be upcoming uh in
2024 sure
uh uh let me let me uh walk uh you all
through this
slide going with the days when a data
scientist or the data engineer has to
focus only on the tabular data data may
come in any format data may come in the
form of a picture in the form of a video
or
audio okay so data may come in any
format and data engineer or data
scientist should be able
to work with that data not only work
with that data but to be able to they
should be able to extract the hidden
insights out of
that okay so computer vision
handles image
processing it handles video
processing and here deep learning comes
pretty handy it is not traditional
computer vision computer vision
using convolution neural network
computer vision using generative
AI okay so this is a very H skill and
people are looking forward to hire in
this
domain time Ser analysis it has always
been a very hot is skill forecasting
basically time series analysis helps you
to forecast for the
future forecasting helps to do the
planning forecasting helps
to set the targets for the
salese it is very useful transfer
learning transfer learning uh basically
is used especially in deep
learning you don't have to create the
model from a scratch building a model is
not very easy it is time consuming it is
very costly so if you already have
pre-trained
models how you can leverage pre-trained
models to solve any problem that is all
about transfer
learning basian statistics basian mod
methods have always been very effective
to solve different problems generative
AI I talked about generative AI multiple
times even before this
slide generative AI if you
know you
are kind
of
uh very very important resource for the
company people are actually searching
for those people who are good at
generative
AI neural architect search Big Data
Technologies like Hadoop and
Spark cloud
computing AWS Azure Google
Cloud distributed
computing because uh we need to deal
with enormous amount of data Big
Data computation becomes very
challenging so distributed computing
comes into picture here which increases
the efficiency Edge AI
natural language
generation Aid driven cyber security
cyber security is of Paramount
importance for different
companies AI optimized
Hardware the
Hardwares uh which can help you to
increase the efficiency of your program
when you're dealing with huge amount of
data you're dealing with millions and
billions of images how will you process
that with the help of gpus with the help
of
tpus okay
so uh these are the hotest skills in the
AI in ml
space thanks thank you so much sham for
taking us through the hottest skills in
the AMS space in in 2024 uh so we have
basically talked about the skills we
have talked about uh basically the
career paths you can take up in4 uh and
we have even talked about the PO tools
and Frameworks you know which you can uh
choose from in the upcoming year uh if
you're aspiring to be become an IML
expert uh and take up a career in AIML
so uh we want to understand what is the
biggest challenge here you're facing
when it comes to becoming an AIML expert
or taking up a career in AIML so I've
just launched a poll uh basically where
this is a multiple choice question poll
so you can choose multiple options so we
would love to know what exactly is
stopping you from becoming an AIML
expert so you can see four or quick
options here I'll just read out those
options for you the first one I can't
find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum second one I
don't have the Practical exposure I need
to become job ready uh third one I find
it difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and the last one my work should
won't allow me enough time for learning
so as we know that we've gotten a lot of
experience folks here so I think that uh
option definitely makes sense um but as
I was speaking I think almost half of
the folks have already shared the
responses so that's great as I mentioned
earlier we've gotten an active set of
you know audience and aspiring Learners
here so thank you so much for that but
for other folks like other folks we are
still basically going and basically
choosing their options there please do
let us know on this poll basically what
exactly is stopping you what is the
biggest challenge here we would like to
understand before we move
forward uh in case this poll does not
cover your concern you can let us know
on the chat here as well so feel free to
do that or in the Q&A box your concern
here and also uh we actually have
already started getting a lot of
interesting questions in the Q&A box uh
so thank you so much for actively
participating and sending your queries
here so uh you basically your curiosity
fuels the heart of our discussion and we
we eager to address your uh queries here
we'll be doing that in some time uh
Hussein says poll is not coming you can
see the poll on basically it should be a
popup on p pop up on your screen please
check it out in case not you can let us
know on the chart here you can see on
the slide you know if your biggest
concern with us so I think most of the
folks have already shared their
responses for the poll here so let me
quickly end the poll in 5 seconds a few
of the folks please quickly go and share
us basically your biggest challenge when
it comes to becoming an AI AML expert in
the year 2024 so I'll just give five
seconds
more so 5 4 3 2 1 let quickly end the
poll and also share the results with
your folks uh so as we can see that we
have gotten the highest amount of votes
53% votes that I can't find a program
with a fully comprehensive curriculum
and we have gotten 42% of the votes for
my work schedule vote allow me enough
time for Learning and 30% of the FKS for
uh votes for I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure uh I need to become
job ready and we have gotten few of the
words for I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos so thank you so
much for sharing the biggest concern uh
here with us when it comes to taking up
a career in AIML now let's moving on to
the program part here so the
professional certificate course in a
machine learning program by IAT kpur
here comes with a comprehensive uh
industry Aline learning path uh you get
in handson to integrated Hands-On labs
and projects for practical experience
which will be talking about in much more
detail in the upcoming slides and also
online virtual classrooms with life peer
and instructor interaction
and also this program will be flexible
to fit your schedule in case you're a
working professional uh also I think
someone asked about the program ver part
here so the program duration for this
program is 11 months and it can just
complete it by giving 10 to 15 hours per
week so uh and moving on and at the end
of it all you will be getting a program
completion certificate from uh IAT kpur
here and also uh you get exposure to
latest trends like generative AI prompt
engineering charb which we actually talk
to about you know one being one of the
hottest uh basically skills and Trends
in the upcoming year uh this program
covers that and Hands-On projects in
integr including a Capstone one which
we'll be talking much more in detail in
the upcoming slides what Capstone
project what are the Hands-On projects
you get to cover and why exactly they
are important uh if you come from a
completely different background or a
non- IML background we talking more
about that and also the master classes
you get access to are delivered by
distinguished IAT CER faculty here so C
C ific from the I basically ICT Academy
it conf you can see on the screen here
this is the certificate you'll be
getting for completing this professional
certificate course in a machine
learning uh also let's talk about the
IAT Cur Advantage here so uh the Indian
Institute of Technology C uh was
established in 1959 and is a leading
educational institution with an
international reputation uh we are aware
of I gor is home to India's national
blockchain project and the inter Center
for cyber security and cyber defense of
critical infrastructure so having a i
Cur on your CV basically completely
enhances your pro portfolio uh after
you're done with the program and also it
basically is a prestigious
accomplishment as well to have IAT Kor
on your resume um also I think someone
asked what are the eligibity and
prequisites about the
program uh so let me just quickly take
you through the eligibility and
requisites here so uh prior knowledge or
experience in programming mathematics
will definitely help you uh basically if
you're planning to join the program also
a bachelor's degree with an average of
50% or higher marks is preferred in the
program and also two plus years of
formal work experience is preferred so
uh it is not compulsory but it is
preferred if you're taking up this
program so um um sham I just have a
question for you I'm pretty sure folks
who have joined here have a question
that uh it says that prior knowledge or
experience in programming and
Mathematics so what what amount of
knowledge uh are we expecting folks to
have uh and obviously in the program
also they will be taking us through uh
the basically programming and
Mathematics Basics they'll be covering
that as well right can you tell us a
little bit about that sure so uh this is
a very important question uh if you have
any programming background that will
definitely
help if you have mathematical background
that will definitely help but I've been
teaching since a long long
time what I think is
Learners should have proclivity to learn
mathematics procity towards mathematics
is
important I mean a learner should not be
very good at mathematics but the learner
should be able to learn mathematics
mathematics uh he should he or she
should find interesting that is the
first thing second thing for programming
part since we'll be using python here
which which is a high level language
even if you have not learned any
language in the past you should you will
be able to do very well here because we
start from scratch we don't assume that
you have any programming background in
fact the first course is programming
Foundation where we start really from a
scratch so even if you don't have any
background you will be able to pick up
having said all of
that you should be ready to learn that
is the most important part you should
have high high appetite to learn and if
you have high appetite to learn you will
be able to do very well in this field so
having a logical bent of mind is
enough uh thank you so much for
answering that shabam I think that makes
sense uh I think being curious is the
solution here uh when it comes to
programming and Mathematics uh so moving
on how this program basically prepares
you so let's take us through the steps
sure so I find this uh very
structured uh it starts from mathematics
and statistics
essential this is the first course you
start from so even if you don't have any
mathematical background I used the term
procity inclination natural inclination
towards mathematics if you if you're
somebody who wants to learn mathematics
you'll be able to learn here whatever is
required for the course at the very
outset and then the next course is
programming
refresher Foundation of Python
Programming over there we start with the
very basics of Python Programming and
then you move to apply data science with
python so in applied data science with
python you will be learning data
manipulation data wrangling part part
Data pre-processing before going for the
model building before using any advanced
algorithm what all you do with the data
that is data pre-processing that all
you'll be learning in this course that
these all things you'll be learning with
the help of python and then you will go
to machine learning
course in machine learning you will be
learning supervised learning
unsupervised learning recommendation
engines time series analysis Etc
and uh afterwards you'll be getting into
deep learning with Kaz and tensor flow I
talked a lot around Kaz and transer flow
so I think now you have an idea about
that then comes the essentials of
generative AI so this course it starts
from very Basics and then covers here
very
contemporary subjects which are actually
required in the industry nowadays which
is which are in high demand in the
industry so Essentials of generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and finally
we have got
Capstone Capstone I will talk about in
detail uh in the next slides apart from
that I also want to talk about these
amazing electives you can see here
reinforcement
learning Advanced deep learning and
computer vision it's a very interesting
course same goes with natural language
processing and speech
recognition and then finally you also
have here academic and Industry master
classes uh thank you so much sham for
taking us to the SK steps here uh also
the electives I think sham I was already
mentioned so they come as a part of the
program they are optional we don't
charge anything extra for this so it is
up to you if you want to take up this
awesome El here of the program so moving
on uh we have get basically have been
getting a lot of questions about the
tools libraries and the platforms I
think we covered a lot of these uh you
know trending Tools in 2024 uh so um
maybe can you take us through these
tools but I think uh someone I we see a
lot of questions from folks who are
coming from a completely different
background here so what would you
suggest you know how how how can they
get started in this field what tools uh
you know they should take up before uh
you know like uh basically moving
towards the program what are the tools
they should consider sure so uh you'll
see most of these
tools are used within
python so the first step would be to
Learn
Python Master
python so for that the first course is
uh programming foundation so that
programming Foundation course will
prepare you with uh this skill with this
tool python once you have very good
knowledge of python you will be able to
move
further for example pandas you can learn
pandas library is there in Python which
is a kind of One-Stop shop
onetop Library you don't have to go for
anything else for data manipulation to
deal with table data you can use pandas
then you have nltk here natural language
toolkit which helps you to perform all
the text mining tensor flow I talked
about for deep learning tensor flow
Keras pitor then I can also see here mat
plot a mat plot lip Matt plot lip helps
in data
visualization chat GPT you all know I
don't have to talk much about that open
CV again for image processing SK learn
is a kind of again onetop shop you have
many other libraries as well for model
building but SK learn gives you a lot
many uh functions to work with many
statistical models different types of
statistical models flask you
have uh Jango uh helps you to create a
good uiu environment yeah
so that's how you can go about so start
with python and then you can build uh
Castel on top of
that uh thank you so much for taking us
to these in demand tools libraries and
platforms we are getting a lot of
questions and we'll be addressing those
pretty soon uh please do let us know uh
if you have any queries you can let us
know in the Q&A box moving on uh as we
mentioned earlier that you get to work
on in uh multiple Hands-On projects uh
with real business implications here in
this program uh you can see like retail
production bfsi and many more like that
we cover in this program and also caps
projects which you can basically work on
to showcase to your future employees
here what exactly are Capstone projects
Capstone project may make real life
business scenarios for True experience
you can Showcase in your portfolio uh
you get to basically choose one out of
several based on their preference uh so
um like I'm pretty sure the audience uh
here has a question here how does having
like a capson project and also these
industry aligned projects uh you know
with from this program in your in your
portfolio once you're done with the
program how does it help for someone who
does not have any experience in IML uh
is not a coder you know uh is not that
proficient in mathematics and
programming before joining the program
does not have any experience how does
having these projects help in uh
basically when they're trying to get out
there uh to and land their dream job in
2024 how does it help can you tell a can
us a little bit about that shba sure uh
so
uh if you uh look at uh this AI course
there are three aspects
tools where we are learning python where
we are learning deep learning
Frameworks we are learning uh different
libraries SK learn nltk etc etc so that
is the tool part then we have the other
pillar as
techniques where we learn different
mathematical techniques statistical
techniques right then the third part is
domain
knowledge domain knowledge is about the
knowledge of the industry
knowledge of the problem you're solving
so ultimately tools and techniques
you're going to use to solve
problems okay problems of different
domains so we need to marry the
three so it's not about learning python
it's not about learning some statistics
it's about
using statistics as well as python
statistics as well as tools to solve
problems how you develop problems
solving
skills Capstone projects help you with
that and once you complete Capstone
project you able to demonstrate people
that yes you have problem solving
abilities using tools and techniques so
Capstone projects actually prepare you
completely they make you industry ready
here in Capstone project you start the
project from the
beginning you don't work on cooked up
data
you start from the raw data you perform
all the data manipulation steps from the
beginning then you build your model so
end to endend you work in the
project this gives you the opportunity
to walk in close to real life scenarios
and Capstone projects are actually
complex the complexity level of Capstone
project is very high so you get an
experience of real work here that you
can mention on your CV as well on your
resume as well that will help you in
your
career uh that sounds pretty interesting
and the projects you know can add to
your portfolio uh in the coming year
2024 in IML uh now basically uh we have
a simply learn Community which actually
supports you the learner get access to
instructors cohart manager program
manager learning teams and uh peers and
curriculum resources will be talking
more about that uh so the Elms learning
environment for the professional
certificate course in AIML by ID Kut
sham can you take us through the LMS
here quickly uh also um I think I have I
have uh basically uh sent you like few
questions here from the Q&A box because
we have gotten plenty of questions I
think it will be very hard to find uh
the questions here so I'm just sending
you the questions here so folks don't
worry we'll be addressing your queries
one by one now moving forward and shba
will be taking you through the LMS the
learning environment of the program here
just to give you a much more uh in-depth
you know uh view of the program here
what exactly happens so over to you
sham uh meanwhile shubam is preparing to
share her screen uh I think Wasim has
asked a question can I get the slides
through uh my email so Wasim we don't
share the slides but we actually do
something much better we actually share
the recording of the session itself so
not only the slides but actually you can
uh go through the recording of the
session once again so you can expect
that for not only for Bim for everyone
who's attending uh with uh over mail
once the session is done uh you can
basically uh get the recording of the
session in case you want to go through
it again uh that includes the slide of
the session like you can view that very
easily then sure sure please go ahead
sh so here in the learning environment
we'll be covering uh you know what
exactly happens in the program what
exact happens when you basically take up
the program so sham will be taking you
through
that sure rash are you able to see my
screen folks please do let us know on
chat here are you able to see the screen
uh which ASP kobam have shared great
awesome so this is simply learn LMS I I
really like simply learn elements it is
very useful for the Learners and as well
as for the trainers so simply Lear LMS
is a kind of
onstop uh Place onetop shop for all your
learning
needs so this is your LMS what I'll do
I'll go to the program here I have a lot
many uh courses I teach so your course
is this one I'll go to this program
so you can see here all your courses are
aligned here of this
cohort so for this track all the courses
aligned here course one course two
course three course four course 5 6 7 8
last one is Capstone and the first one
is induction then we've got maths and
statistics essential
then programming refresher then apply
data science with python machine
learning deep learning Essentials of
generative Ai and then finally
Capstone okay so if I click on any of
these programs suppose I click here on
machine
learning uh regular updates keep coming
but right now I'll resume
learning
so you can see
here you've got some self- learning
videos here for each chapter you've got
self- learning videos so before you come
to the class you can prep yourself you
can prepare yourself by going through
these
self-based uh videos these recorded
videos then you've got live classes here
okay I don't have here because it's a
faculty portal so you can join your
classes through this LMS from here and
you can download the recordings Etc all
the assessments you have
here okay all the course content you
will get here the
slides the
codes
projects okay then you've got practice
lab
here so for uh running Python scripts we
use Jupiter notebook as integrated
development environment so we can launch
lab and work with the lab it's a
cloud-based lab which gives you the
experience of working in real life
scenarios because mostly you will you'll
be working on cloud-based tool in your
organizations in any AI team so this
gives you a very good
experience
for uh deep learning courses we have AWS
so that also is amazing apart from that
you have access to community here where
you can post your queries you can
discuss amongst your batchmates you can
talk to your trainer you can connect
with your trainer easily with the help
of community so this is uh about your
LMS
thank
you thank you so much sham for taking us
to the learning environment uh of I
campus professional certificate program
in AI machine learning let me quickly uh
share back my screen uh so we basically
shared the learning environment uh you
know in which we covered how you can
manage your curriculum the live virtual
classroom labs and projects test and
assessments and much more like Capstone
project and basically the progress
tracking how you can unlock your
certificates also is a part of the
learning environment and support tools
uh we have uh global leaders as program
uh advisers here uh we have program uh
director so Professor amay Kar who's the
department of computer science
engineering uh director here of I Campo
so basically they make sure that cly
learn is delivering as for the standards
of IAT kpur uh and also we'll be sharing
the learner outcomes here so interesting
part is the previous classes have
consisted of Learners from World Class
organizations and diverse Industries
diverse Industries like I uh it
consultancy others and bfsi and hiring
companies they come from Amazon
cognizant Gena deoy uh TCS evi uh dell
Wells Faro and many more like that uh so
as basically before we move on uh to the
basically enrollment poll uh actually I
have shared a few questions with you
sham because we actually have got a bulk
volume of questions in the Q&A box so
maybe let's start with addressing you
know your queries here about about uh
you know career in general program so uh
basically Wasim has asked Wasim kesi uh
currently I am serving as a general
science teacher uh should I join this
program so since you have joined this
webinar it appears that you are
inquisitive you are interested to learn
Ai and you are already a
teacher so I think you can build build a
career uh into AI teacher AI trainer for
sure because teaching is something which
you learn that this a skill you acquire
over the period of time you can't learn
teaching through any crash course right
so I think it is a good idea to learn Ai
and then uh teach people
AI uh thank you so much for answering
sham I hope aim that answers your
question uh we also have another
question here uh from uh I think gajer I
not able to make out the name please
correct me so I'm 17 years old right now
and I'm already have learned python CSS
and some basic programming languages uh
what else do you prefer I can start or
what are the initial steps you know he
can
take sure I'm so happy uh to know that
you are only 177 and you are so
concerned about about your career and
your
learning so I I believe if you are good
with programming you can build further
on top of that uh by solving more
complex problems apart from that I think
you uh should now focus on mathematical
part as well mathematics
statistics which will be very useful for
machine learning for deep learning so
build your basics
of Statistics
now and
again focus more on Pro problem solving
okay so focus more on problem
solving uh be a part of communities like
kaggle over there you'll find many such
AI enthusiasts as well as experts so you
should be a part of that
community on LinkedIn as well you should
follow uh such such
communities and stay AB breast with the
new development in the
industry uh thank you so much for
answering that sham I hope that answers
your question please do let us know on
the chat or in the Q&A box uh so we have
one interesting question from Sor of
Dave here uh he says that hi I'm a 45
year old uh be Electrical uh pgdm and
marketing with 10 years of work
experience and eight years of career Gap
uh will this course help me restart my
professional career
anyway so uh let me start with uh a
cliched statement AG is just a
number I'm also uh around
40 and believe me I spend daily around 3
hours to learn new things
that's three hours I provide to learn
new things so age is just a
number if you are able to uh learn AI
tools and techniques and
complement the knowledge you have gained
in the
industry you will definitely be able to
get into a good job and you can uh
become a Lynch pin over
there because
I told you domain knowledge again is
very difficult to master in a few months
or in a few years domain knowledge you
gain when
you uh go through the business nuances
over the period of time so that you
already have if you're able to
complement that with AI skills you can
fetch a good job and you can be
indispensable over there as well
depending on how you push yourself so I
think that will definitely help
you thank you so much for answering that
shba Ma definitely age is just a number
and staying curious you know definitely
is the approach you know we all should
take uh when it comes to uh you know
learning new things uh yes we are
getting a lot of questions here as
promised I will be addressing all of
those questions we have a special
duration for the Q&A part here uh before
we move on uh we have a quick poll
question for you to understand your uh
interest towards the I conforce program
uh in professional certificate program
in EA machine learning so we have
covered you and there is a bonus offer
as well for attending the webinar so
there are two quick options here you can
let us know uh by voting for the option
yes if you're interested in joining uh
into the program if you're interested in
enrolling into the program so uh as we
have talked about the skills the hottest
skills the hottest career Trends you
know upcoming in AIML 2024 you can
basically uh you know pursue through
this program here and also the tool the
Frameworks the in demand platforms the
Capstone project you get to add to your
portfolio also coming from a completely
non AML background that helps you helps
you get give that work experience which
is required you know when you get out
there and you want to showcase some kind
of experience so are you interested in
enrolling into the IAT compos uh
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning please let us know
through this PO here so uh based on that
I'll be taking you through the
enrollment steps of the program and
sharing the program fee and the schedule
for the upcoming cohorts here also uh
folks just to make sure uh so we only
take a very limited uh folks you know
per cohart in order to make sure that
you know getting all the attention that
is required when you take up this
program so we only take 25 to uh 30
folks per cohort uh so uh we have taken
you through the learning environment of
the program uh we have taken you through
uh you know the basically the electives
here which basically you get access to
into the program how this program goes
step by step also uh so as I was
speaking I saw a lot of interest towards
enrollment here so that that's great uh
but I'll just give 15 seconds more for
the folks who are still thinking about
it and let's not forget about the bonus
offer for attending this webinar you'll
be getting uh you know through this uh
basically uh program so uh I'll just
give 15 seconds more and as we are
speaking we actually are getting more
questions volumes in the Q&A box here
which we'll be addressing uh in the Q&A
part of the session in just few minutes
uh so keep the questions coming in we'll
be addressing your queries as much as
possible and also uh we'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program as
well so let us know that are you
interested in enrolling into IAT coners
professional certificate program in uh
EI and machine
learning so you can see a quick poll on
your screen here which says what you
like to enroll into the program uh that
is how you can Avail or also the bonus
offer which you'll be getting uh for
attending this webinar
here I think someone has asked about the
program fee uh so I'll be sharing that
in the upcoming slides uh and uh also
about uh basically a lot of questions
about the program andl career in general
so we'll be taking those questions as
well uh folks who are putting down their
questions in the chat box here I'm so
sorry we already have plenty of
questions in the Q&A box so if you want
your queries to get answered you can let
us know in the Q&A box we'll be taking
questions from there so folks who have
already shared you know questions there
before beforehand so we'll be going
through step by step of those
questions awesome I think I'll just give
10 seconds more uh also let's utilize
this time right let's utilize this time
uh while folks are sharing their
interest towards enrollment to the
program through this poll uh you can
utilize This Time by asking questions
you have you have joined the session
because you're interested in NL I'm
pretty sure you have a lot of questions
uh even if it's a very simple small
question please don't hesitate to ask we
will address uh you know all your
queries as possible and uh we are very
eager to move towards the Q&A part of
the
session awesome I think most of the
folks have already shared their
responses their interest towards the
enrollment in the poll here so I'll just
give five seconds more for the folks uh
for basically if you want to share sh
your interest uh in the program
enrollment uh and uh I'll be then moving
on to the enrollment steps of the
program so 5 Seconds more so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the
poll thank you so much we saw a lot of
interest towards enrollment and I think
I think s is also saying yes my response
is yes so that's great let's move on to
the enrollment steps here for folks who
have already shared their interest
towards enrollment of the program how
does exactly it work so you need to
basically follow these three simple easy
steps uh you need to submit an
application to us at ask us.net based on
that your application will be going for
review based on the eligibility uh
criteria for the program and also based
on that you'll be getting uh admissions
offer letterer like and the learning
Consultants from simp will be contacting
you uh based on the basically when do
you plan to enroll is something I'll be
asking you in the upcoming slide So
based on that we'll be understanding
when do you plan to enroll and reach out
to you
also uh the enrollment schedule and the
program fee for the program so the next
upcoming cohort for the program is 30th
November the induction classes start
then and uh the classes will be starting
on 16th of December this year uh the
program fee for uh this IAT compost
professional certificate program in AI
machine learning is 1 lakh
15,400 including uh taxes uh and uh I
think someone asked about if there are
any in options available so we do have
that you can Avail that at just
5,220 uh rupees per month uh also as I
mentioned that if you have any questions
if you need any more support you can
always reach out to us ask as R I'll
just share that email ID quickly on the
chat here in case uh you need this email
ID if you have any questions you can let
us know on this chat this email ID here
and also let me share the program link
also in case I I saw that a lot of folks
have joined from uh different countries
apart from India so in case you want to
look out uh for the basically what is
the program fee when when are the
upcoming cohs for your own region you
can check out in this link which I've
shared here also as I've mentioned
earlier that the upcoming cohorts which
we take we only take 25 to 30 folks per
cohort uh in order to make sure you're
getting all the attention that is
required in the program uh so uh for
folks who have already shared their
interest towards enrollment I just
launched a quick poll before we move on
to the Q&A part of the session uh that
bend do you plan to uh enroll how soon
do you plan to enroll into the program
uh so uh you can see four quick options
here immediately it's the first option
second one within three months third one
within six months and the last one more
than six months from now uh for folks
who want to immediately join the
upcoming Cod they can choose immediately
as the option for folks who are still
thinking about it have shared interest
in enrollment and they still uh
basically are not sure when to start so
I would say you can select the within 3
months within 6 months more than six
months from now option because we have
corts upcoming throughout the year and I
also told you about the limited Sease
option so uh you can Avail the bonus
offer in um in this duration any time of
the year so that is not an issue at all
so I would suggest to select any of the
later CS in case you are still planning
you're not sure when to start so yeah I
think as I was speaking folks have
already started sharing uh when do they
plan to enroll that's great uh we'll be
moving towards the Q&A part of the
session and take more questions uh
towards the end of the session uh we
have exceeded few minutes of the session
sham are you okay to give like five
minutes more to address few queries
which not at all a problem awesome
awesome thank you uh I'll give five
seconds more for the poll here folks uh
so how soon do you plan to enroll into
the program this is for the folks who
have already shared with us interest in
enrollment in the poll which was before
this uh poll so please do let us know in
this poll when do you plan to enroll so
this will give us understanding when do
we exactly reach out to you uh you know
with the offer letter for joining the
program and also you can Avail the bonus
offer as well with the
program awesome I think I just give five
seconds more so five 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll thank you so much
for sharing when do you plan to enroll
now let's dive into the Q&A box here so
as we can see we have gotten plenty of
questions here but uh so just to help
you out sh what I'll do is I'll just put
down those questions in the message box
for you here because it will be very
hard to navigate
questions uh okay let me I think uh this
is by husse here uh this is the name I
can make out from email ID please let me
know if I'm uh not correct so uh Hussein
asked that you talked about hidden
insights of data uh can you tell
something more with
examples uh sure and I I I'm very happy
to uh see here that you listen to me so
carefully uh when I say hidden
insights I mean the insights which
you're not able to figure out only by
doing Simple data
manipulation for
example you have data
of uh your customers banking
customers from that data how can you
figure out what type of
customers
actually uh are possible uh fraud
customers possible
defaulters with the help of simple data
manipulation techniques you're not able
to
relate different
fields you're only able to aggregate
data you're only able to filter the data
for the required information so you're
able to do only limited things but uh
with the help of analytics with the help
of advanced algorithms you are able to
do much more than that you able to
develop relationships you able to do the
predictions
okay I'll give you one very simple
example suppose you have last 10 years
data
last 10 years Revenue numbers of a
company with the help of simple
techniques you will only be able to find
out the growth you'll only be able to
find out how
big this quarters revenue is as compared
to previous quarters but if you know
analytics you are able to figure out the
trends you able to figure out uh
seasonality in the data you're able to
figure out the
cyclicity and then you'll be able to do
the forecasting for the future as well
that you're not able to do uh with basic
data manipulation
techniques I hope it answers your
question uh thank you so much sham for
explaining that in so much detail please
let us know on chat here or in the q&
box if if you have any followup question
or it answers your query here so I think
the next next one we have I'm not able
to make out the name from the email ID
but I'll just uh share the question uh
here so as a fintech student what uh
what are the hottest skills you know
that suits me so as a fintech
student uh you uh you can learn credit
risk
modeling a lot is covered in that risk
is a very important aspect to measure
from various perspective
in finance so credit risk modeling uh is
a very important skill to have for a
ftech
student thank you so much for answering
that uh we have uh um like two questions
uh here uh one is by rupes what computer
languages are required to learn for AI
or ml engineer and uh I think by here we
have what road map will you suggest to
be uh to me to become uh an ml engineer
and AI developer all together so I think
it's all but it's s demand yeah uh so so
uh life going forward is very easy for
you my friend uh you can start with
python and most of the framework are are
built on top of python so it is going to
be easy for you so do you should not be
targeting too many languages to learn
you you can uh start with Python Master
one language Master One tool and the
next will become very easy for you so
take baby steps don't get overwhelmed
you will hear too many things but start
with python and then you'll be able to
pick up the rest very
easily I hope that answers your question
thank you so much for taking that uh
also uh let's quickly browse through the
questions here we actually have answered
a lot of these questions
uh so I think this question we get a lot
in the AML sessions can AI affect the
jobs of cyber
security the C uh AI will definitely
have impact on all the fields it it is
having impact it will have its impact uh
but the roles will change it will
actually
augment uh the current the current ways
of working
and it will remove the
redundancies and we'll be we as human
beings will be able to focus on more
challenging more logical aspects of
problem solving okay so that way it will
impact everywhere it's not about cyber
security
only uh thank you so much for diing that
sham let us know on CH if it answers
your basically question let us know on
Q&A box or the chat box uh we have one
question question from nmit here sham
I'll just share with you on chat uh so
uh nmit has asked that hi good evening
uh basically please ask any industrial
application is developed based on deep
learning uh neural network like how much
friction introduced by metal during
during processing process uh it's a it's
a good question nmit in
fact mechanical
engineering in mechanical engineering AI
is used Big Time nowadays in automobile
engineering AI is used big
time so if um I'm in touch with many uh
AI teams which are working in mechanical
engineering
space and these kind of aspects are
addressed with the help of neural
networks and traditional algorithms as
well okay so if you are from uh mechanic
techical engineering
domain I'm sure if you learn AI you'll
be able to contribute and add value to
your organization and to your
industry uh thank you so much for taking
that question I think we'll take one
last question because we already have 10
minutes sham so this is by Deep
maheswari uh says that completed my
graduation few months back in BSC I and
currently looking for jobs internship or
related things in the field of AIML what
should I
do so uh since you already have a
background in it uh computer
languages and Mathematics is not
something new for
you uh you can definitely go for an AI
course you can definitely go for a data
science
course and that you can show on your
resume that will definitely add value
value because BC it only without any job
does
not exhibit that does not show uh that
you are industry ready but uh doing a
professional course will definitely help
the cause you'll be able to show people
that yes you industry
ready uh thank you so much for answering
that question sham I think that is the
last one we will be able to take so
sorry folks uh we have tried addressing
most of your queries here so now about
the program here so uh folks who have
already shared their interest towards
enrollment which I saw a lot of you and
also folks basically you have shared
with us how soon do you plan to enroll
uh we would love to know if you need
assistance uh into enrolling to the
program here so there are two quick
options here yes or no you can let us
know uh with that I will suggest take
the extra help right getting take the
extra help you're getting from Simply
learns learning consultant who can help
you uh if you have any questions about
the program in much more detail so I'll
just give 10 seconds for the poll here
uh you can let us know on this uh poll
basically if you need assistance in
enrolling the program also uh we
addressed almost all of your all queries
as much as possible we also extend the
session for 10 more minutes for you
folks to address uh most of your queries
here uh so would love to uh first of all
thank shba you know taking the time out
for the industry master class today and
sharing with us the popular IML tools
and Frameworks you know in the upcoming
year 2024 and also taking us through the
skills the career paths the hotest
trends here so uh thank you so much shba
for taking the time out and uh taking us
through an interesting session here uh
would you like to see something the
audience before we end the
session thank you so much Rasha for
having me here it is very interesting to
interact with the EI enthusiasts thank
you thank you thank you once again and
also uh thank you so much folks for
being an am amazing audience here and
and uh we saw how much engaging
questions interesting questions you
basically have put down for us to answer
that made the basically the session much
more interesting uh and so sorry if you
not able to answer all of your queries
but we'll do a lot of these sessions you
know uh throughout the month so uh
basically you can check out more
upcoming sessions I'll just share the
link with you folks here uh if you want
to check out the upcoming webinars with
us you can check out in this link here
uh we actually have another IML session
at 9:00 p.m. so folks if you don't join
that you can join that as well and also
uh folks uh if you have any questions if
you require further assistance or
inquiries about the webinar the career
basically career in general or program
in general you can let us know uh in in
this mail ID you can mail to us at ask
us.net I'm just sharing that mail ID
here once again uh your Learning Journey
is a is a priority and we are here to
support you every step of the way so
thank you so much once again for joining
us and uh being an amazing audience here
so thank you so much folks uh also as I
said that we have another webinar lined
up at 9 in case you want to join that
session you can join that session as
well so thank you so much you can find
that in the link I've shared here uh and
we'll be ending the session now also
you'll getting a post webinar survey
email in case you want the webinar
certificate for this basically webinar
industry Master Class you can put down
the full name there based on that only
we can give you the webinar certificate
so thank you so much I'll be ending the
session now uh once have a good evening
good afternoon good morning wherever you
joining us from thank you thank
you